casting is underway right now to find
out who will play madonna in the movie
of her life a hollywood reporter says
competition is stiff everyone in
hollywood wants this part and all they
have to do is impress the director whose
name is madonna
my daughter she's also writing it and
producing it and working with casting
director carmen cuba to find the star
and auditions have been going on for
months and this is who we're hearing is
still in the running right now tell me
okay who watches ozark or inventing anna
okay then you know julia garner she's in
the running florence pugh oscar nominee
from little women is in the running and
alexa demi from euphoria
in the running
as well okay i i have a favorite i think
who'd be so good in this role tell us
okay so i'm obsessed with inventing anna
i just watched it and julia garner i
think is one of the best actresses
around right now i can i look at her on
the left she even looks like madonna she
does look like a young madonna right
give her that little gap tooth gold salt
i am such a florence pew fan of course
so i mean she can do action she can do
period there's nothing she can't do
and miss demi from euphoria also has
that hot moxie that madonna had
she just kind of catches you in her web
whenever she's on camera she's got such
spine these are just great women so i'm
very excited well you know why because
with madonna's story there's a lot of
material girl
stupid stupid
i i is
well next up it was fashion week in
milan and paris and the main event was
the red carpet but you know who owned it
rihanna as usual the woman who literally
changes the world with each decision
that she seems to make
she showed us again how to be a pregnant
woman
out in the world and put that baby bump
front and center she's literally showing
people kind of how to celebrate the
pregnant body i've not seen someone
dress
time and time again in their pregnancy
the way that she's doing it she's she is
breaking the mold uh yet again like she
always does
always yeah the like the hottest trend
at fashion week is the womb yeah you
know exactly and rihanna brought it yeah
thank you rossi you put better words
into my mouth
well up next uh more movie news how
about this a cult classic might be
getting a sequel 34 years after it first
came out nylon reports beetlejuice part
two is in the work say it three
times yeah the script and the cast are
not confirmed yet but here's what we
know brad pitt's production company plan
b has officially taken on the project
and they're partnering with warner
brothers right now they're working on it
together so could we see winona ryder
back is lydia dietz all grown up or
michael keaton back and oh please that
is one of the most iconic performances
in the history of time
michael keaton as we all do ever
you know i auditioned for beetlejuice
for
uh i'm just imagining winona writer's
party yeah okay yeah and um and then i
saw her at a party and she was like
yeah i just booked a movie
and i was like really and
what is it and she was like
beetlejuice
and i was like
oh
i'm so happy for you i uh
i'm gonna go make a straight to video
movie with chris christopherson hit
rehab and then i'll see you two years
later at the academy awards you'll be
wearing couture i'll be wearing betsy
johnson
you'll be with christian slater i'll be
with corey feldman oh my god
that's the best story ever drew
but she actually taught me
my most valuable lesson in life what is
that
always be happy for people oh yeah
that there is enough room
to go around for everybody and
everybody's timing is different and
i just fell in love with her because
winona ryder for me is a symbol of how i
conduct myself in life and she's like my
poster girl for
knowing that you need to celebrate
everybody's wins come on
i know
you just got that that was a kid all
right and
as we go into commercial break i want to
give a shout out to another great young
woman who i'm totally obsessed with joey
king she's a friend of this show she's a
friend of mine and she just got engaged
to her boyfriend stephen and i just want
to say a big congrats from all of us
here at the show
[Music]